zu den treffen impfen eben wirkung mehr
männer oder frauen wissen sie zu all
diesen fragen haben mediziner der
johannes gutenberg universität in mainz
geforscht eine umfangreiche
langzeitstudie veröffentlicht heute
10.000 menschen haben sie befragt pcr
test gemacht blutproben genommen
und hier sind die ergebnisse und hier
bei uns im studio ist der mann der diese
ergebnisse heute vorgestellt hat wir
freuen uns sie hier begrüßen zu können
professor viele bild herzlich willkommen
er will kann man sagen das ist die erste
richtig große studie zu corona in
deutschland nein ich glaube dass das ist
so nicht richtig es ist die erste große
bevölkerungsrepräsentative studie zu der
sehr viele daten vorliegen vor daten in
ihrer tiefe ist das sicher eine
besondere studie
wir kommen gleich natürlich ausführlich
auf die ergebnisse aber einfach mal
vorweg würden sie sagen in der studie
ist vieles bestätigt worden was man
geahnt hat oder gibt es auch richtige
knaller richtige überraschungen beides
wir haben vieles neues gelernt was uns
überrascht hat aber natürlich auch ganz
viele dinge von denen wir wussten
vermutet haben aber was uns vor allen
dingen in dieser studie möglich ist ist
die dinge zu quantifizieren sie etwas
genauer und exakt einschätzen zu können
einfach mal mit zahlen die sachen
belegen zu können wie gesagt das sind
die ergebnisse
wir haben einige davon kurz und knapp
zusammengefasst das schauen wir uns kurz
an und danach feuer frei auch für ihre
fragen zunächst aber der überblick die
studie zeigt dass viele menschen mit dem
virus infiziert waren ohne es zu wissen
das trifft auf gut 42 prozent zu knapp
58 prozent wussten von ihrer infektion
die sogenannten aha regeln haben gut
funktioniert
konsequentes abstand halten und das
tragen eines mundschutzes konnten das
ansteckungsrisiko deutlich senken
und auch wer ausschließlich im
home-office gearbeitet hat hatte ein
niedrigeres risiko kinder begünstigen
laut der studie eine infektion nicht
ein haushalt mit mehreren kindern hat
ein etwa gleich großes risiko wie ein
durch großer haushalt nur mit
erwachsenen also der professor will das
haut nicht jetzt irgendwie um 40 prozent
der korona infektionen bleiben unerkannt
das ist also das ergebnis ist eine
gigantische dunkelziffer das ist eine
hohe zahl ist durchaus früher mal auch
höhere zahlen in den raum gestellt
worden
nun haben wir eben sie mit 40 prozent
festlegen können das heißt auf 10
wissentlich infizierte kommen acht
unwissentlich infizierte dass das eine
ganze menge mehr in deutschland als wir
derzeit auf den zahl auf dem dashboard
zum beispiel das robert-koch-institut
sehen was noch erstaunlicher war
was wir lernen dürfen das häufiger
ältere menschen unwissentlich infiziert
sind und das geht so weit dass das in
der höchsten untersuchten altersgruppe
75 bis 88 jährige zwei drittel der
menschen betrifft
zwei drittel der infektion dort sind
unwissentlich abgelaufen und das war
sehr erstaunlich für uns was hat das
denn jetzt direkte folgen wo dafür
folgen sozusagen auf unser denken oder
wenn wir jetzt über die zukunft reden
die wir mit corona umgehen das heißt
erst mal grundsätzlich dass ein stück
weit die infektion natürlich etwas ihren
schrecken verliert dass wir die zahlen
etwas korrigieren müssen an der
häufigkeit schwer zu erkranken oder auch
zu versterben
das heißt aber auch macht natürlich die
vielen schwerkranken menschen und
verstorbenen nicht ungeschehen dass wir
alle unsere risikoanalysen noch mal
genauer anschauen müssen und dass wir
auch überlegen müssen wie wir die
villmarer variablen gruppen ältere
menschen besser schützen können
also da zeigt sich ja die dunkelziffer
ist als noch höher weil den älteren eben
auch jetzt einfach mal fragen
von denjenigen die unwissentlich
infiziert sind wie ist das verhältnis
zwischen männern und frauen gibt es auch
einen unterschied
ja in der tat wir können sehen dass
männer häufiger unwissentlichen
infektionen durch machen und das führt
so weit dass insgesamt mehr männer als
frauen die infektion hatten
wenn wir auf die seiten vom
robert-koch-institut gucken auf die
wissentlichen infektion in deutschland
dann waren das mehr frauen in der tat
und eine ursache dafür könnte sein neben
natürlich einem unterschiedlichen
so verhalten dass männer auch häufiger
von der infektion nicht verspüren
also da vielleicht die reaktionen dann
eben nicht so stark sind kann das eine
ein grund sein spielt denn die bildung
die sagen wir mal soziale
gesellschaftliche schicht auch irgendwie
eine rolle
absolut menschen mit höherer bildung mit
höheren sozioökonomischen status wissen
häufiger von ihrer infektion und
umgekehrt sind menschen die sozial
benachteiligt sind gefährdet da haben
ein höheres infektionsrisiko und das hat
natürlich auch implikationen jetzt für
die nächsten schritte zum beispiel auch
in der impfkampagne
denn da ist nicht nur ein höheres
impfrisiko ein höheres infektionsrisiko
sondern auch eine niedrigere impfquote
da gehen wir gleich noch mal ausführlich
darauf ein jetzt haben wir aber in der
zusammenfassung auch gerade gehört die
aha regeln wirken doch eigentlich ganz
gut da würde ich jetzt sage okay das
überrascht mich jetzt nicht ganz aber
sie konnten dass er jetzt quantifizieren
was sagen denn die zahlen wie senken wie
stark senken denn die aha regeln wenn
ich sie einhalte sozusagen das risiko
einer infektion
genau wir haben die menschen befragt wie
häufig sie die regeln jeweils befolgen
und menschen die nie oder selten zum
beispiel angeben den abstand einzuhalten
haben ein doppelt so hohes risiko wie
menschen die das immer oder fast immer
tun also abstand halten reduziert das
risiko auf die hälfte etwa das legen die
daten nach das tragen eines mundschutzes
reduziert das risiko ungefähr um ein
drittel
wenn im vergleich wenn ich das nie mache
zudem wenn ich es immer oder fast immer
tue wenn es geboten ist
das war auch einfach noch mal gut zu
sehen tatsächlich das funktioniert und
das funktioniert auch über alle
schichten und situation hinweg und
gleiches wie auch ausgeführt für home
office abstand ist generell wichtiger
und effektiver als mund nasen schutz und
homeoffice aber alles hat einen
eigenständigen effekt also haben wir das
jetzt sozusagen schwarz auf weiß ich sag
mal bisher hat man sich vielleicht
gesagt wer im home office arbeitet ist
nun vielleicht weniger gefährdet als der
busfahrer als die krankenschwester als
die kassiererin im supermarkt belegen
dass auch die zahlen sozusagen
absolut so ist es natürlich haben
bestimmte berufe die auch gar nicht ins
home office konnten dann ein höheres
risiko aber diese zahlen die ich gerade
genannt habe sind korrigiert worden für
diese faktoren das heißt also unabhängig
davon bringt home office auch innerhalb
eines gleichen berufs zwischen menschen
die den zu hause oder eben am
arbeitsplatz aus ihren definitiven
schutz und ja menschen mit berufen
bestimmten berufen sind natürlich
deutlich gefährdet da immer auch dort wo
man viel kontakt mit anderen menschen
hat also noch mal schwarz auf weiß das
eben wenn man gesagt hat da muss man ja
applaudieren beziehungsweise sagen das
ist schon eine enorme leistung was
manche menschen in manchen berufsgruppen
eben zeigen unterstreicht das ganze
nochmal also heiko schulze hat sehr
aufmerksam schon zugeschaut und die
zusammenfassung verfolgen stellt sofort
über youtube die kritische frage
die kinder sind der studie zufolge keine
pandemie treiber heißt es aber die
inzidenz der jüngeren altersgruppen ist
mehr als doppelt so hoch wie der
durchschnitt was ist damit gemeint wenn
sie sagen die kinder sind keine pandemie
treiber das was wir untersucht haben
sind nicht direkt die kinder selbst
sondern menschen ab 25 auch wer hat aber
wir hatten 2200 menschen in der studie
die in einem haushalt mit kindern leben
und wenn kinder die infektion leichter
verteilen würden dann müssten alle die
haushalte in denen kinder leben eine
höhere infektionsrate haben und das
sehen wir ganz klar nicht trotz
korrektur für stöhr variablen familien
mit kindern wohnen vielleicht in haben
den anderen sozioökonomischen staaten
das wohnen an anderen wohnorten haben
ein anderes alter
all diese faktoren herausgerechnet sehen
wir keinen unterschied und haben keinen
hinweis dafür dass kinder die infektion
in einer form anheizen wasser eine rolle
spielt dass die anzahl an personen im
haushalt und da ist es gleich ob
erwachsener oder kind umso mehr leute in
einem haushalt leben
umso mehr ist um so weniger quadratmeter
stehen typischerweise pro kopf in der
wohnung zur verfügung und das ist ein
faktor der das infektionsrisiko bestimmt
also beengte wohnverhältnisse also das
spielt jetzt manch einer meint
vielleicht auch die kinder bringen jetzt
das virus mit
aus der schule aus der kita das heißt
also eltern die zwei kinder haben sind
gefährdeter als vielleicht vier
erwachsene die zusammen in einer wg
wohnen also würden sie sagen es ist
nicht so sondern das ist ja das ist
alles gleich das ist richtig dass es
nicht so auch vielleicht wegen den daten
der aus der dunkelziffer die wir sehen
man sieht das auch sehr schön an der
impfung die impfung ist eine simulierte
infektion auf die das immunsystem
reagieren müssen und was sie sehen junge
menschen unter 30 da sind über 90
prozent mit einer impfreaktion auf die
impfung
und das geht dann ab 40 nach unten bis
etwa zu den 60 jährigen und älter da ist
das nur noch jeder fünfte und dadurch
die impfreaktion dass die weniger stark
ausgeprägt bei älteren ist erklärt auch
warum mehr menschen eine infektion in
höherem alter nicht bemerken wohin gehen
die jüngeren menschen dass wir merken
das heißt also auch ein kind was eine
krone infektion hat wird wird das
durchaus bemerkt er
und das macht die wahrscheinlichkeit
natürlich auch das infektion sich
ausbreiten unbemerkt geringer jetzt sind
sie ja gerade dabei und sagen die
impfreaktionen wie heftig reagiert man
auf die impfung habe ich ein gehens
gefragt jetzt kommt die lösung sozusagen
er reagiert den mehr frauen oder männer
sind tatsächlich die frauen zwei drittel
der frauen haben eine in fraktion und
praktisch jeder zweite mann nur also 50
prozent versus 68 frauen müssen auch
deutlich häufiger zur schmerz medikation
greifen um mit der reaktion zurecht zu
kommen das ist doppelt so häufig und das
passt aber auch wieder zu den
infektionsdaten bei männern verläuft die
infektion häufiger unbemerkt deswegen
auch die impfreaktion die weniger
ausgeprägt ist bei frauen häufiger
bemerkt deswegen mehr wissentlich bei
frauen ist häufiger die infektion
bekannt
und das erklärt auch analog warum frauen
häufiger eine impfreaktion haben denn
dass das genau die reaktion auf diese
infektion wollen wir sofort die
anschlussfrage von mir hier aufnehmen
die geschrieben wird die studie ist doch
einsehbar richtig an die leute sind so
adressiert und möchten sozusagen schwarz
auf weiß die zahlen sähen sie haben es
heute veröffentlicht der
ministerpräsidentin überreicht aber
jeder kann die sozusagen anklicken sich
angucken
das ist korrekt also wir haben schon
seit anfang diesen jahres ein dashboard
zur studie in dem man auch die daten im
zeitverlauf sehen kann viele daten und
die daten die wir heute vorgestellt
haben sind teilweise bereits auf der
internetseite und werden jetzt in den
nächsten tagen dort weiter ergänzt
werden also wir wollen die strategie
fahren dass all das was wir zur studie
ermitteln wir auch immer der
öffentlichkeit zur verfügung stellen
dann sind das ja schon mal spannende
antworten sie haben aber auch geschaut
die studie hat auch danach geschaut ob
denn gesellschaftliche schichten der
wohlstand die sozioökonomischen dinge
der status eine rolle spielt kurz und
knapp einige ergebnisse zusammengefasst
besonders betroffen von der pandemie
sind laut studie die menschen mit einem
niedrigen sozioökonomischen status
bedeutet menschen mit geringem einkommen
oder nur wenig wohnraum in sozialen
brennpunkten zum beispiel ihr risiko
sich mit corona zu infizieren es demnach
um rund 60 prozent höher und zwar auch
wenn sie sich an die hygiene regeln
halten
grund dafür vor allem der geringe
wohnraum pro person
außerdem hat die pandemie die
geringverdiener finanziell stark
getroffen
circa jeder vierte hat jetzt noch
weniger geld als vor corona das virus
macht die armen also noch ärmer gut und
besserverdiener trifft die pandemie
dagegen weniger stark und die menschen
mit niedrigerem sozioökonomischen status
lassen sich weniger impfen dazu sagen
die forscher die impfkampagne müsste
verbessert werden
professor wir da sind ja spannende
sachen aber erklären sie das noch mal
ist es wirklich so zu sagen jetzt
untermauert dass sozusagen die
lebensverhältnisse wohlstand etc
die gesellschaftliche schicht sozusagen
eine rolle spielt was das
infektionsrisiko angeht impfbereitschaft
etc
hat man das bisher vielleicht völlig
übersehen ich glaube wir hatten schon
einige hinweise in der pandemie an der
einen oder anderen stelle dass dies so
ist und das konnte auch diese studie
belegen
was die überhand eindrucksvoll ergänzt
hat ist es dass es nicht nur das höhere
infektionsrisiko ist sondern eben auch
ursachen dafür die zum beispiel nicht im
verhalten liegen denn wir sehen wenn wir
menschen zum beispiel untersuchen in
beengten wohnverhältnissen im vergleich
zu menschen die nicht diese situation
haben dass sie sich mindestens genauso
häufig an die hygiene regeln halten
nicht wenige an großen versammlung
teilgenommen haben auch im lockdown
weniger gereist sind mehr die maske
tragen also insgesamt vom verhalten
mindestens genauso gut sind und dennoch
ein höheres infektionsrisiko haben was
zum einen durch den wohnraum bedingt ist
was zum anderen sicher auch durch
faktoren wieder weg ein home-office was
möglich ist zb bedingt ist und ja dazu
kommt dann das ausgerechnet bei höheren
infektionsrisiko dann auch noch die
impfquote geringer ist und das war der
grund weswegen wir gefordert haben dass
dort nachgebessert werden muss jetzt
sagen sie aber auch die impfbereitschaft
steht auch im zusammenhang mit den
lebensverhältnissen lebensverhältnisse
und war doch jetzt was meinen sie damit
das hat das damit zu tun dass man anders
kommunizieren muss risiken usw
die ford hat einen anders erklären muss
dass vielleicht auch mal nicht nur auf
deutsch auf englisch in anderen sprachen
was ist damit gemeint ja das ist sicher
vielschichtig das ist auch ein faktor
das dass wir richtig kommunizieren
müssen was die vorteile einer impfung
sind und was ihre möglichen risiken sind
und wie die risiken zu bewerten
einzustufen sind andere faktoren sind
aber sicher auch dass menschen die
sozial benachteiligt sind schlechte
geschlechter in eine impfung ankommt das
ist vielleicht nicht im bekanntenkreis
die ärztin oder der arzt über die man
vielleicht auch möglichkeiten hatte an
eine impfung zu kommen informationen
über die priorisierung zu bekommen aber
auch schlichtweg ob man überhaupt einen
hausarzt hat der 1
mit 1 bestellt oder einem die
möglichkeit eröffnet auch die
versicherung die krankenversicherung
spielt natürlich bestimmt mit eine rolle
und das hat sich ja alles einfluss
gehabt in der pandemie in der
reihenfolge in der die menschen geimpft
worden sind also hoch spannende
erkenntnisse auf die man vielleicht dann
dringend reagieren müsste allein eben
solche erkenntnisse wo man anders
aufklären muss man anders kommunizieren
muss sie bleiben hier vielen vielen dank
bis hierhin sage ich einfach nur denn
wir wollen jetzt noch jemand anderes ins
boot holen
die studie kommt ja genau zu einer zeit
wo heftig debattiert wird gestritten
wird über das wie weiter
gestern schlug der deutsche
lehrerverband alarm
man befürchtet dass wenn die schule
wieder startet nur zehn prozent der
650.000 unterrichtsräume luftfilter
haben
da sei man nicht gewappnet heute nun
fordert die bundesschülervertretung und
schülern ein impf angeboten gemacht
werden sollte und es wird diskutiert ob
die korona maßnahmen nun für folge
impfte fallen sollten das fordert
zumindest der bundesaußenminister wir
sprechen gleich darüber mit der
vorsitzenden des deutschen ethikrats
frau professor alena büchs zunächst aber
die reaktion auf die forderung von
außenminister maß die reaktion heute
ganz frisch heute morgen vom
gesundheitsminister von jens spahn
bei denjenigen die geimpft sind haben
wir ja was kontakt beschränkungen angeht
auch nächtliche ausgangssperren während
der bundes notbremse
all diese maßnahmen auch schon
ausgenommen auch quarantänemaßnahmen
sind geimpfte ja weitestgehend
ausgenommen zurecht weil sie geschützt
sind für sich und auch deutlich weniger
andere anstecken können aber was ich
aber richtig finde ist dass wir jetzt
auch vor allem auch mit blick auf august
dass wir nicht versprechungen halten und
auch nicht verwirren
in der debatte nicht versprechen machen
die wir schwer halten können die maske
im innenraum insbesondere wenn mehrere
in einem innenraum sind im herbst und
winter
die wird es auch wieder brauchen das ist
sehr klar
ich finde aber im vergleich von allen
einschränkungen ist das maske tragen
noch die harmloseste also geimpft sein
macht einen unterschied wer viel wieder
machen können will vom stadion bis zur
partie bis zum familientreffen bis zum
berufsalltag mit viel sicherheit der
sollte sich impfen lassen und möglichst
viele davon überzeugen aber wir werden
sicherlich zumindest die basismaßnahmen
die aha regeln und dazu gehört auch die
masken bestimmten bereichen noch eine
ganze zeit brauchen
soweit der gesundheitsminister heute
morgen und jetzt haben wir sie auch
dabei ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich frau
professor büchs die vorsitzende des
deutschen ethikrats namen genannt harry
k jetzt haben sie es selbst gehört die
reaktion vom gesundheitsminister auf den
außenminister der eine sagt nun ja man
sollte doch als anreiz für alle geimpfte
sagen für alle doppelt geimpften sagen
die maßnahmen sollen dann auch fallen
und der gesundheitsminister sagt nein
langsam heu wägelchen maske tragen das
sei ja nun auch nicht so schlimm was
sagen sie denn
also ich will mich ungern zwischen zwei
minister linken geben aber vielleicht
können wir das ein bisschen auseinander
bröseln wir sind da im moment einfach in
einer übergangsphase
leider ist das ja so dass jetzt die
delta variante in deutschland auch
vorherrschend ist also über die hälfte
der fälle gehen inzwischen auf die delta
variante zurück und bei der weiß man ja
dass man da wirklich den doppelten
schutz braucht den haben in deutschland
aber nur 40 prozent der bevölkerung also
da ist nur noch ordentliche wegstrecke
zu gehen
das ist das eine und das andere ist das
ja immer argumentiert wird wenn man
allen ein angebot gemacht hat dann gäbe
es keine argumente mehr für geimpfte
noch einschränkungen aufrecht zu
erhalten
und da ist auch wichtig dass das ein
echtes angebot sein muss dieser begriff
ist oft an die knappheit der impfstoffe
gebunden gewesen nachvollziehbarerweise
weil das ja bisher alles beschränkt hat
aber da möchte ich durchaus was auch
greifen was sie gerade mit hellen
bildschirm diskutiert haben ein angebot
muss man auch hürden frei annehmen
können also es gibt eben menschen die
haben nicht ein hausarzt oder die leben
ewig weit weg vom nächsten impfzentrum
es gibt menschen die sind sprachlich
noch nicht erreicht worden
es gibt auch immer noch skepsis es gibt
durchaus berechtigte fragen also ich
würde sehr dafür plädieren viel zu
kommunizieren und auch wirklich
aufsuchen
um zu machen dahin zu gehen wo die
menschen sind und wenn man das eine
weile gemacht hat dann kann man
ernsthaft sagen man hat ein angebot
gemacht aber da sind wir noch nicht vor
letzter punkt die kinder und
jugendlichen das ist einfach eine große
herausforderung
die haben sehr viel mitgemacht die haben
noch keine allgemeine impfempfehlung
oder noch gar keinen impfstoff beim und
da gibt es einfach eine verpflichtung
gesellschaftlich die mit zu schützen und
denen auch zu ermöglichen dass sie ein
halbwegs normales schulleben haben
können wenn die sommerferien rum sind
und aller letzter punkt es ist
tatsächlich so die maske ist jetzt keine
stark die grundrechte einschränkende
maßnahme die ist lästig und unangenehm
aber sie gehört jetzt nicht zu den
maßnahmen bei denen man sagen würde also
das sind wirklich die harten dinge und
wir haben vom deutschen ethikrat gesagt
solche grundrechts schonenden
instrumente die sind auch für geimpfte
noch eine weile zumutbar
also dass wir weiter zumutbar dann sind
sie so ein bisschen auf der linie des
gesundheitsministers der sagt das ist ja
wohl das harmloseste könnte man machen
und wenn ich sie richtig verstehe es
wäre eben unfair weil ja immer noch
leute auf die zweite impfung warten sie
zu gefährden wäre sozusagen nicht
richtig und ja kinder und jugendliche
haben nichts davon wenn der
bundesaußenminister sagt na ja doppelt
geimpft dann kann man doch sozusagen
alle maßnahmen fallen lassen
das passt ja sozusagen für die jüngeren
dann eben nicht trotzdem der manch einer
geht ja eben hin und sagt wir müssen
aber doch anreize schaffen dass sich
mehr leute impfen lassen
kommen wir zu dem thema impfmuffel das
ist auch nur ein ganz ganz aktuell weil
die bundesregierung verstärkt bei
impfstoffen für die korona werbung für
die korona impfung werben will und sagt
selber wir müssen die bestehende
impfkampagne lauter stellen so ganz
aktuell die nachrichten heute und da
sagt eben manch einer jahr sozusagen in
aussicht stellen dass die maßnahmen
gelockert werden dass die regeln dann
wegfallen das wäre doch auch ein toller
anreiz sozusagen die impf motivation zu
steigern
also ich muss ihnen sagen mir kommt
dieses laut stellen fast zu spät
das ist etwas das sagen die
forscherinnen und forscher die sich mit
motivation beschäftigen schon ziemlich
lange dass man da wirklich voll
reingehen muss und vor allem auch
spezifisch für unterschiedliche gruppen
kommunizieren sollte das zweite ist dass
es eben viele gibt das bin ich aber das
sind kolleginnen und kollegen die sich
damit beschäftigt haben womit man
menschen am ehesten dazu bewegen kann
diesen schutz wirklich anzunehmen und
sich selbst impfen zu lassen
und das ist tatsächlich vor allem eine
gute wertschätzende kommunikation das
ist die aufsuchende impfung also dass
man so die alltags führten einfach weg
nimmt und es einfach macht gerade für
diejenigen für dies nicht so einfach war
oder die mit der digitalisierung schwer
tun und wie gesagt im zentren die keinen
betriebsarzt haben solche dinge kein
hausarzt und dann erst wirken
tatsächlich anreize aller art also diese
beiden maßnahmen sind den anreizen
tatsächlich überlegen nichtsdestotrotz
ist das ja tatsächlich jetzt schon so
das ist ziemlich viele anhalts begibt
sich impfen zu lassen weil er für die
geimpften schon eine ganze reihe von
dingen möglich geworden sind für die
sich menschen die noch nicht sich impfen
lassen konnte neben testen lassen müssen
und das ist ja schon unterschied das
merkt man jetzt ja immer mehr dass man
sozusagen wenn man diese 3gs hat geimpft
genesen getestet dass es doch
beträchtlich einfacher ist wenn man eben
das im zertifikat vorzeigen kann
gerade auch zum beispiel natürlich beim
reisen aber auch in vielen anderen
kontexten also ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wir schon jetzt sondern mischung
haben und deswegen würde ich sehr dafür
plädieren dass auch suchende impfen
deutlich zu verstärken gut zu
kommunizieren und immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen dass die impfung nicht nur
schützt nicht nur einen selber schützt
sondern auch andere schützt und dass man
damit ja auch den einen oder anderen
vorteil hat dass andere gvb konnten sie
nicht sehen das heißt nämlich gelegt
denn herr professor bild hat yannick
stimmt ihnen zu sie haben ihm quasi aus
dem munde gesprochen
er will das sehen sie auch so das ist ja
das was sie eben angeschnitten haben es
fängt schon mal an
mit kommunikation die leute tatsächlich
sozusagen aufsuchen auch in prekären
verhältnissen und nicht nur in
villenvierteln ist absolut herbigs
angesprochen hat all das sind faktoren
wie wir diese menschen erreichen können
das geht um die kommunikation es geht um
die ansprache es geht um das beseitigen
von barrieren das heißt vor ort impfen
können am arbeitsplatz impfen können
aufklären auch was das risiko einer
impfung bedeutet im verhältnis zu
anderen risiken im leben
und ganz wichtig sicher auch was was
frau wuchs auch gesagt hat die
information dass ich damit nicht nur
mich selbst schütze wenn ich mein risiko
vielleicht als gering erachtet sondern
dass es vor allen dingen auch um den
schutz anderer menschen geht jetzt haben
sie beide im grunde genommen fragen die
die userinnen und user hier schicke
nightmare reality schreibt sie über
youtube warum sind jetzt lockerungen
angedacht wenn doch gerade die vierte
welle anfängt wäre es nicht klüger bis
herbst diese neue welle aus zu stehen
beziehungsweise einzudämmen und dann
entspannt in den winter zu kommen
sprich stichwort eben delta ist das
etwas was auch die dinge noch mal über
den haufen werfen kann und was auch noch
mal ein punktes weshalb man eben beim
thema lockerungsmaßnahmen das ganze
überdenken sollte vor wächst also da
gibt es jetzt sehr unterschiedliche
hinweise aus anderen ländern in england
sieht man leider gerade das auch die
krankenhausaufnahmen wieder richtig hoch
gehen das ist sehr unangenehm aus israel
ist wird das noch nicht berichtet aus
israel allerdings wiederum hört man dass
die wirksamkeit der impfstoffe bei delta
eventuell niedriger sein könnte und dass
auch geimpfte noch relativ häufig dieses
virus weiter geben also nicht so ganz
aus dem pandemie geschehen verschwinden
das muss man sich jetzt ein bisschen
angucken aber solange man sich das
anguckt darf man natürlich nicht den
fehler machen zu glauben das wird
jedenfalls das positivszenario werden
ich glaube da hat man hoffentlich aus
dem letzten herbst gelernt dass man
einfach wirklich aufmerksam bleiben muss
weil diese varianten haben leider die
unangenehme angewohnheit dass sie die
dinge nicht einfacher sondern schwerer
machen und der zweite punkt der mir
wirklich noch wichtig ist und da möchte
ich auch noch mal auf das eingehen was
sehr wild gesagt hat da sind wir uns ja
beide eigentlich mit dem andere schützen
es ist einfach tatsächlich so dass wir
eine gruppe haben die noch gar keine
oder nur wenig chancen bisher hatte sich
impfen zu lassen und das sind die kinder
unter 12 bei denen geht das noch gar
nicht und wird auch absehbar noch
wirklich dauern
und das sind eben die jugendlichen und
gewissen inzwischen aus vielen studien
wie belastet diese gruppe ist und dann
möchte ich wirklich auch an alle
appellieren bei jedem verständnis dafür
wie schön das ist jetzt im sommer
endlich mal wieder das leben zu genießen
und ein bisschen zu vergessen was wir da
alle hinter uns haben dass man nicht
vergisst dass die sommerferien in
einigen bundesländern wirklich im august
schon wieder vorbei sind und dass wir
alle gemeinsam noch ein bisschen
vorsichtig sind für diejenigen die sich
wirklich noch gar nicht so gut schützen
können und das sind eben die kinder und
auch die jugendlichen haben sie das noch
mal aufgegriffen was ich eingehen
ja auch gesagt hatte gestern hat der
deutsche lehrerverband alarm geschlagen
und gesagt wir müssen diese zeit die
sommerferien nutzen nicht wie letztes
jahr den sommer verstreichen lassen und
etwas tun sei es luftfilter dinge machen
und nicht einfach die zeit daher rennen
lassen
das interessante ist dass der
finanzminister vizekanzler olaf scholz
heute sagt er rechnet für das kommende
schuljahr mit einem normalen unterricht
die fortschritte in dem kampagne stimmen
mich optimistisch dass ein normaler
schulunterricht möglich sein wird
allerdings kein wort davon dass
irgendwie investiert wird oder die ärmel
hochgekrempelt werden
er will sie nicken auch bei dem thema
schüler jugendliche kinder absolut also
das ist die gruppe die bis jetzt noch
kein schutz hat und ich glaube ich die
eine große last in der pandemie getragen
hat und auch das gehört zum
gesellschaftlichen gleichgewicht das wir
diese diese gruppe weiter schützen wir
haben noch nicht die empfehlung für die
impfung bei den jugendlichen nur bei
kindern mit vorerkrankungen die daten
aber wachsen jeden tag und ich denke
dass wir bald eine bessere
datengrundlage haben dass die experten
von der ständigen impfkommission hierzu
auch eine entscheidung treffen können
und die impfung das wird noch ein wenig
dauern denn wir müssen das dann erstmal
staaten beginnen durchführen
ich finde es toll dass da so viel wille
da ist aber ich glaube auch wir brauchen
noch ein bisschen geduld und das können
wir nur überdauern mit den
hygienemaßnahmen die wir alle in der
pandemie gelernt haben dann wollen wir
aber einfach mal diejenigen hören über
die wir gerade sprechen denn ich habe es
auch schon angeschnitten
heute haben sich die schüler zu wort
gemeldet die bundesschülerkonferenz der
sprecher ein kurzer überblick über die
diskussion heute impftermin an der
hochschule koblenz luisa ist studentin
jung gesund über den normalen im weg
wäre sie vielleicht nicht so schnell
dran
diese sonderaktion quasi eine abkürzung
angst vor delta hat luisa nicht macht
aber mit auch für die schüler
entscheidet sich jetzt wie es nach den
ferien weiter geht
ihre vertreter fordern daher zumindest
ein angebot für alle ab 12 noch in den
sommerferien und da so früh wie möglich
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt in
eben am anfang der ferien die erste
impfung als angebot erhalten und eben am
ende die zweite dann können wir
sozusagen einen immunschutz staates
gewährleisten
ein extra programm für schüler im sommer
also der gesundheitsminister will sich
da nicht festlegen weil es die
impfkommission für diese altersgruppe ja
auch nicht tut gleichzeitig bewirkt der
massiv um die eigeninitiative der jungen
ich finde wir sollten einfach die kinder
und jugendlichen selbst entscheiden
lassen und wer für sich das möchte dem
machen wir das möglich auch bis
spätestens ende august die erste impfung
und dann auch bald die zweite impfung zu
bekommen schüler ab 12 und studenten
zusammen genommen
das sind in deutschland immerhin fast
neun prozent der gesamtbevölkerung die
spannende frage also reichen die impf
anreize der einen und die bereitschaft
der anderen damit das land sicher in den
herbst gehen kann
ja das ist tatsächlich eine große frage
und die frage reicht man einfach mal
weiter an sie beide frau brooke ladies
first
wie sehen sie das also ich glaube man
sollte mal darauf hinweisen dass er das
robert koch institut mit ganz
interessante modellierung jetzt gerade
wieder veröffentlicht hat wie hoch die
impfquote in deutschland sein sollte
damit es keine welle gibt keine vierte
welle bei der wieder richtig viele
menschen ins krankenhaus müssen und da
gibt es einen wirklich enormen sprung
zwischen dem tode von 65% doppelt
geimpft und für 79 prozent und noch
besser ist natürlich 85 prozent und für
diese 75 prozent rechnet das rkw auch ab
12 das muss man sich einfach schon bei
gegenwärtigen ich glaube das wichtigere
argument ist immer der individual schutz
und da ist die individuelle entscheidung
der jugendlichen gemeinsam mit der
familie und ärztinnen und ärzte
sicherlich ganz klar um das
wesentlichste aber es ist in der
gegenwärtigen situation auch mit zu
berücksichtigen dass sozusagen zum
eigenschutz auch weitere überlegungen
gehören können wie zum beispiel sicheren
guten schulbesuch also wir müssen da aus
allen rohren schießen wenn die ständige
impfkommission keine allgemeine
empfehlung gibt dann wird es keine allzu
breite impfung beiden jugendlichen geben
weil dann auch viele ärztinnen und ärzte
ein bisschen zurückhaltender sind damit
dass anzubieten
und dann muss es andere maßnahmen geben
da muss es einfach dann ein bündel geben
um sicherzustellen dass die jungen
nicht mehr einen solchen verlust in der
schule aber auch im berufs anfang in der
ausbildung im studium usw haben
herr professor wird liegt auch sozusagen
nicht nur das impfen
also es ist ja so eine mixtur eben
einerseits der schülersprecher vom
bundesverband fordert so zu sagen alle
nein impfangebot zu machen natürlich ist
das freiwillig die ständige
impfkommission hat es nicht empfohlen
nicht empfohlen heißt aber nicht dass
sie davon abrät
nur ist die frage wir werden jetzt nicht
irgendwie nullkommanichts sämtliche
schüler und studenten mal eben geimpft
haben das heißt diese große
bevölkerungsgruppe heißt das also mit
allen anderen maßnahmen wie frau wird
aus allen rohren schießen also weiterhin
vorsichtig sein
ich glaube beim beim impfen die ständige
impfkommission weg nutzen risiko ab für
die für die schüler und bevor dort eine
empfehlung ausgesprochen wird möchte man
sich sicher sein dass man da tatsächlich
kein höheres risiko als ein 1 1 nutzen
hat und ich denke dass das dass wir gut
beraten sind dem im moment zu folgen
ich bin nicht ganz glücklich mit mit der
mit der situation dass man sagt wir
übergeben das den jugendlichen
selbstverständlich sollen sie mit
entscheiden
das ist eine wichtige diskussion aber
ich glaube auch da ist wichtig zu
erklären wie die entscheidungen dort
stattfinden
ich wäre er dann dafür noch die
schutzmaßnahmen sowie wir sie etabliert
haben weiter fortzuführen
als kinder ein risiko auszusetzen weil
ich denke in unserer verantwortung für
die nächste generation die wie vorhin
schon angesprochen so viel getragen hat
gehört auch mit dazu eine impfung ihnen
ans herz zu legen und nahe zu legen wenn
wirklich auch dass mit vertretbaren
risiko machbar ist alles deutet darauf
hin das muss man ja ganz klar sagen und
es gibt länder in der welt die das alle
machen
deswegen bin ich sehr optimistisch dass
wir zeitnah auch an den punkt kommen wo
wir das wirklich mit guten gewissen oder
auch von den experten die empfehlung
bekommen und dann sollten wir das auch
um
übrigens machen und ich denke es ist
extrem positiv dass wir so eine
bereitschaft unter den jugendlichen
haben und ich glaube da springt auch
ganz mit neben dem rauskommen aus diesen
diesen maßnahmen auch das helfen wollen
und das unterstützen wollen wir haben ja
eine sehr aktive jugend das sehen wir
auch auf anderen gebieten die die die
die wir etwas ändern möchte in unserer
welt und nur glaube ich wir müssen
aufpassen wir sind haben da auch eine
verantwortung
sodann über skype das nicken
verwirklicht werden muss das wirklich
einfach unterstreichen was keine
alternative ist dass man jetzt sozusagen
sagt wir machen gar nicht also weder
schutzmaßnahmen weder testen
sonstiges noch macht hat man ein breites
angebot das eine hängt ein bisschen mit
dem anderen zusammen
und wenn das eben die situation noch so
ist dass es keine breite
impfempfehlungen gibt dann muss man die
anderen regler hoch ziehen
ich bin aber ganz bayern will ich bin
eigentlich auch ziemlich optimistisch
gestern nicht vergessen vor ein paar
tagen hat die amerikanische
gesundheitsbehörde eine
vorveröffentlichung gemacht zu den 30
millionen zwölf- bis 18-jährigen die
inzwischen in den usa geimpft sind
und die haben ganz klar gesagt denn
nutzen überwiegt in dieser altersgruppe
das risiko das sind natürlich
amerikanische daten aber die sind jetzt
mal vor veröffentlicht und ich bin sehr
zuversichtlich dass die ständige
impfkommission die sich auch anschauen
wird und auch viele andere daten
anschauen wird die zeichen sind positiv
schlechter wäre es gewesen wenn da jetzt
was rausgekommen wäre dass es
irgendwelche negativen erfahrungen mit
dem vorgänger scheint überhaupt nicht
der fall zu sein und das stimmt mich
eigentlich ganz positiv dass wir dann
doch zukünftig eben auch die impfung für
die jugendlichen hoffentlich haben
werden aber jedenfalls jetzt müssen wir
wirklich ganz viel tun um für diese
menschen für die jungen menschen das
herbst halbjahr nicht katastrophal
werden zu lassen
ich greife jetzt mal auf was sie sagen
alle regler hoch ziehen solange sie
liegen auf einer linie die
die ständige impfkommission wird diese
daten sicherlich analysieren sammeln etc
und wenn die ständige impfkommission
genügend daten hat dass sie sicher sagen
kandidaten geben her dass man wirklich
sagen kann der nutzen überwiegt die
risiken dann würde es diese empfehlung
geben sie sagten aber bis dahin muss man
alle regler sozusagen hochziehen und sie
ihr professor wild haben hier in dieser
studie ja auch einen regler sozusagen
gesehen der wieder runter gefahren wird
sie haben nämlich das test verhalten der
menschen ja auch untersucht nicht
erinnern uns wochenlang haben wir darauf
gewartet dass endlich test zur verfügung
gestellt werden ob jetzt im testcenter
oder der selbst erst zu hause
und was haben sie denn jetzt
festgestellt ja seit ende mai geht in
der bevölkerung das test verhalten also
die bereitschaft zur testung deutlich
zurück das feld ab und das betrifft
insbesondere menschen die chinesen sind
und die bereits die volle impfung haben
und mit delta variante im land bei der
hälfte der infektionen glaube ich ist
extrem wichtig dass wir dort auch weiter
testen um ein frühwarnsystem zu haben
gibt es lokal ausbrüche wir haben wir
hinweise für das eintragen einer neuen
variante denn nach delta kann die
nächste variante kommen kann es sein
dass dir der der virus weiter mutiert
und möglicherweise resistent gegen eine
impfung wird um also was früh zu
erkennen brauchen wir ein geschicktes
system dazu muss es überlegungen geben
ob man bei genießen bei bei vollständig
geimpften zum beispiel gezielt an
bestimmten stellen in referenz gehörten
regelmäßig misst um ungenau und testet
um genau das zu tun
wir sehen den rückgang dieses tests
verhaltens und das ist sicher nicht
unter alle regler ziehen zu verstehen
also dann würden sie sagen weiter testen
ich meine sie haben ja auch deutlich
gemacht wenn ihrer studie wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist und dass man ja also da
auch weiterhin beobachter gut sein
sollte
der entscheidende punkt ist aber diese
delta variante markus schmidt schreibt
über youtube was macht die delta
variante so gefährlich im gegensatz zur
ursprungs variante gibt es studien die
die gefährlichkeit der delta variante
erklären und begründen wenn ja welche
allerdings erstmal der mediziner fragen
ja ja zur delta variante das dass das
große problem ist haben eine sehr hohe
infektiosität das heißt eine schnelle
verbreitung und wir haben zunächst
gesehen dass zwar auch in england
mobilität und krankenhauseinweisungen
nicht hochgegangen sind aber enorme
fallzahlen über 30.000 menschen wieder
infiziert die großveranstaltung beim
fußball wo ganz viele menschen
zusammenkommen und das ist natürlich der
ideale nährboden dass sich so eine
variante ausbreiten kann
und wenn die variante bei so vielen
menschen kocht vorliegt dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass sich das
virus weiter verändern kann und dass es
dann tatsächlich zu veränderungen kommt
die zu schweren infektionen führen und
wir haben schon die verschiedenen
varianten eben durch und das wird
weitergehen
und das ist nicht nur bei uns im land
und das ist nicht nur in europa sondern
dass es auf der ganzen welt die pandemie
ist noch ganz aktiv wir sind noch lange
nicht mit dem impfen durch und deswegen
ist delta so gefährlich dann kommt
direkt die anschlussfrage an sie frau
wuchs an die medizinerin haram bb
schreibt über youtube was ist denn eine
vernünftige exit-strategie nach delta er
hat ja angedeutet nach delta kommen da
dann kommen so mega wasser immer was
dann
es kommt doch eh immer wieder neue
mutationen da schwingt ja mit dass
jemand sagt ich möchte mal wissen wann
wirklich schluss ist aber sie sagen eben
das geht noch weiter das ist echt die
gretchenfrage also das gute ist ich
finde man muss auch die guten sachen
unterstreichen delta scheint als solches
jetzt nicht gefährlicher zu sein
also man wird nicht kränker oder es
werden nicht mehr menschen proportional
kränker ließen einfach wahnsinnig
ansteckend und es gibt offensichtlich
eben hinweise darauf dass auch die bei
doppelt geimpften ein gewisser
prozentsatz bis mich riesig aber es sind
ein paar prozent und das kann durchaus
was ausmachen
auch noch mal schwer erkranken kann
aber insgesamt ist es eine gute
nachricht dass das jetzt nicht die
killer variante ist die pandemie
insgesamt ist so vollständig richtig
erst vorbei wenn die ganze welt
geschützt ist muss man sich klar machen
denn selbst wenn wir perfekt geimpft und
perfekt geschützt wären selbst dann
würden in anderen gegenden der welt
könnten ja noch mutation entstehen
die vielleicht dann wiederum zu uns
rüberkommen können das heißt das sagen
viele viele expertinnen und experten so
richtig vorbei ist das alles erst wenn
in der ganzen welt auch flächendeckend
geimpft und geschützt wurde
und daran muss ganz intensiv gearbeitet
werden deswegen müssen auch die länder
die jetzt wirklich ausreichend impfstoff
haben helfen das in anderen gegenden der
welt über bugs initiative und andere
solche initiativen beim auch impfstoffe
tatsächlich breiter verfügbar werden
dass der eine punkt für uns werden wir
sehr viel früher eine deutlich bessere
situation haben
aber ich glaube ein kluges exit szenario
bedeutet ganz hohe durch info
denn nach aller wahrscheinlichkeit
werden hoffentlich auch die mutation die
vielleicht noch kommen trotzdem durch
die impfstoffe insoweit gedämpft als man
dann nicht mehr schwer erkrankt oder nur
sehr wenige menschen schwer erkrankten
und gleichzeitig basismaßnahmen noch ein
weilchen gerade in den wintermonaten im
herbst und in bestimmten kontexten wo
man engen in geschlossenen räumen
zusammen ist bisschen weitermachen und
testen
das testen ist kein großer eingriff in
die grundrechte und dadurch lernt man
sehr viel es gibt ja unterschiedliche
formen von tests und auch solche tests
sie uns sagen können sind dann neue
mutationen die kommen also man muss ein
bisschen nach vorne testen an den
grenzen sollte man wirklich viel testen
und es werden gerade frühwarnsysteme
entwickelt von unterschiedlichen
institutionen die man dann auch
einsetzen kann gibt es alles mögliche
also abwasser screening aber auch alle
möglichen anderen modelle mit denen man
da immer
garantiert die uns hoffentlich warnen
können ob da noch mal was um die ecke
kommt selbst wenn wir alle sehr sehr gut
geimpft und geschützt sind in
deutschland also ich bin verhalten
optimistisch man sollte jetzt nicht
verzweifeln wir sind auf einem sehr sehr
guten weg aber es ist eine pandemie
was bedeutet die ganze welt ist
betroffen und deswegen darf man nicht zu
tun als wäre jetzt alles vorbei
jetzt gibt's zwar sehr interessante
fragen
man kann sie richtig stellen wir haben
wir nun zwei experten mike strider
schreibt über youtube als geimpfter kann
man das virus noch weiter reichen eine
herdenimmunität kann es doch nie geben
jetzt setzte er etwas voraus ist das
richtig wenn er sagt als geimpfter kann
man das virus noch weiter reichen und er
schlussfolgert daraus dann eine
herdenimmunität kann es dann so nie
geben
ist das richtig ich glaube dass das
steht im widerspruch zum einen ist es so
ist es richtig
man kann das virus weiter reichen aber
wir wissen die leute die geimpft sind
kriegen deutlich weniger wahrscheinlich
überhaupt eine infektion sie weniger
schwerwiegend und auch die zeit in der
sie infektiös sind ist deutlich kürzer
das problem im moment ist die
übertragung an nicht geimpfte personen
und davon haben wir noch zu viele aber
eine herdenimmunität sollte eigentlich
erreichbar sein weil es dann wieder an
menschen kommt die sozusagen das virus
nur kurzzeitig haben und damit sinkt die
wahrscheinlichkeit stetig dass man es
weiter tragen kann
menschen die geimpften zum teil nehmen
es dann auch gar nicht mehr gar nicht
auf und deswegen doch eine
herdenimmunität ist sicher erreichbar
eine frage ist noch bei wie viel prozent
wird es tatsächlich der fall sein wie
weit musst du durch impfung seien da
gibt es modellierungen und ideen und
vorstellungen aber da werden wir sicher
auch dann noch in der pandemie wirklich
lernen müssen beim das erreicht ist also
die hoffnung dass wir eine
herdenimmunität erreichen
die wollen wir dann doch weiterhin
behalten ja verwirkt
sie haben das gerade so schön gesagt man
muss auch in die zukunft blicken das tut
auch gisela zu über youtube und fragt
wie uns
wann ist denn eine dritte impfung
sinnvoll da sie ja recht zu sagen dass
man mal nach vorne blicken muss um nicht
sozusagen alles wieder von vorne die
gleichen fehler das warten und auf der
stelle treten zu wiederholen ja das ist
eine wirklich wichtige und spannende
frage
es gibt ja länder die das jetzt sogar
schon beginnen und alle sollten es
vorbereiten denn da gibt es
unterschiedliche studien die zeigen dass
es erstens menschen gibt die von
vornherein leider sehr schlecht
immunität reaktionen nach einer impfung
dh sie haben ein herunter gesetzes
immunsystem beispielsweise nehmen
bestimmte medikamente oder haben
bestimmte erkrankungen und deswegen wird
bei denen die impfung einfach schlechter
und bei denen müsste man dann so nennt
man das aber es scheint auch so zu sein
dass bei sehr alten menschen und das
sind ja gerade die die am meisten
gefährdet sind
durch dieses virus auch der impfschutz
nachlässt das kann man noch nicht in
stein meißeln wann was genau der fall
ist der laufen studien und müssen aber
weitere studien laufen
aber man sollte beginnen das
vorzubereiten und an am sinnvollsten
wäre es eben für die gruppen bei denen
man die höchsten risiken durch die
erkrankung selbst hat und die höchste
wahrscheinlichkeit hat dass der
impfschutz nachlässt und das sind eben
sehr alte menschen und menschen mit
bestimmten vorerkrankungen
dann passt direkt die frage an sie beide
dazu denn manuela quellen gesierich
schreibt über facebook sie haben sie ja
nicht angesprochen die älteren menschen
die ja sehr gefährdet sind dass man dann
da wieder pustet oder auffrischt wie
auch immer
aber sie schreibt ich arbeite in der
intensivpflege ende dezember meine erste
maxi nation mein erster impfung im
januar meine zweite brauche ich jetzt
eine booster impfung frage mal an sie
beide frau wuchs wollen sie hier
speziell der spitze
ich bin ich bin also ich bin zwar
medizinerin aber da ist natürlich auch
nicht spezifisch qualifiziert weiß aber
von den kolleginnen und kollegen dass
sie auf diese art und diese fragen
meistens so reagieren dass es eben die
möglichkeit gibt mal die
neutralisierenden antikörper
zu messen und ich habe heute gerade
wieder einen kollegen aus der
immunologie gehört der darauf
hingewiesen hat dass es zusätzlich zu
diesen antikörpern das ist ja das was
man tatsächlich messen kann auch noch
eben ja doch gute hinweise gibt dass die
so genannte t zell immunität recht
stabiles bei jüngeren menschen also
eigentlich können war relativ
hoffnungsvoll schauen wenn man nicht zu
denjenigen gehört die eben irgendwelche
probleme im immunsystem haben oder
bestimmte medikamente nehmen müssen und
wenn man nicht sehr alt ist dann hat man
schon eine ganz gute chance aber ich
glaube in dem fall werden wir noch sehr
viel mehr evidenz bekommen und zwar auch
relativ bald weil dadurch viele studien
laufen und wir auch natürlich die
beobachtungsdaten bekommen das aus
israel und den ländern wo schon sehr
viel früher sehr viel geimpft wurde
sodass wir dazulernen können und dann
kann man hoffentlich in ein zwei monaten
diese frage sehr viel knackiger
beantworten
aber das ist doch prima vorbild wir
werfen nämlich alles wissen in einem
topf um die frage zu beantworten herr
wild ich würde mich den absolut
anschließen
ich denke auch wie frau brooke gerade
gesagt hat wir wissen dass ältere
menschen und menschen mit bestimmten
vorerkrankungen eher dazu neigen den
schutz wohl zu verlieren darauf daten
deuten die daten bisher ein
und wenn es für die damen nicht zutrifft
dann wäre sie sicher im moment nicht
unter den personengruppen die als
allererstes dort gehen müssen oder
sollen denn wir sehen ja auch das mit
den schutzmaßnahmen die wir auch auf
eine intensivstation haben durchaus das
personal vor infektionen schützen können
und es werden die daten jetzt kommen
denn wir sammeln immer mehr und werden
bald besser wissen wen zuerst impfen
wenn früher impfen bei wem versagt die
impfung und bei wem muss sich früher
wieder ran
diese daten werden in kürze kommen
aktuell ganz klar gibt es noch keine
empfehlung die dritte impfung
durchzuführen und dann kommen wir zum
schluss auch noch mal mit einem blick
nach vorne nämlich wie man alles
bewertet sibylle jordan schreibt über
facebook mich würde interessieren warum
jetzt noch immer an den ins ziel
danson festgehalten wird ja letztes jahr
haben wo instituts in der folge zu
vollen intensivstationen geführt klar da
war es also tatsächlich so man kann es
mehrfach sehen hohe instanzen zwei drei
wochen später haben sich die
intensivstation gefüllt das sollte doch
jetzt wegen der geimpften risikogruppen
eigentlich nicht mehr passieren
sie überlegt jetzt weiter was ist also
so schlimm daran wenn jetzt jüngere
positiv getestet werden das sagt doch
nichts darüber aus wie schwer jemand
erkrankt ich verstehe dass konzentrieren
auf die instanzen einfach nicht also die
frage wie will man den weiter messen so
zu sagen ab wann alarm ist bisher haben
wir das mit der inzidenz gemacht sieben
tage incidents etc oder muss man auch
diese ja alarmsysteme sozusagen
justieren vorbild in der zukunft um
sozusagen richtig zu reagieren
also das ist eine zweigeteilte frage zum
ersten teil dem stimme ich wirklich zu
und das tun auch die meisten inzwischen
dass das immer stärker auseinander fällt
krankenhauseinweisung intensiv belegung
und so weiter auf der einen seite und
instituts auf der anderen mit immer
höheren im quoten sieht man das in ganz
vielen ländern und das ist auch bei uns
jetzt schon so und wird immer stärker
werden deswegen plädieren eigentlich
alle die sich mit diesem bereich
auskennen inzwischen ganz ganz klar
dafür dass man neben der inzidenz die
man auch noch angucken sollte um einfach
sozusagen ein bisschen pandemie dynamik
weiter im blick zu halten die
krankenhauseinweisungen ganz wesentlich
anschauen muss das passiert in vielen
ländern ohnehin schon also auch in
vielen bundesländern ohnehin schon
aber dass da jetzt weitere indikatoren
rolle spielen müssen das ist völlig klar
nicht zustimmen würde ich dem zweiten
teil da muss man wirklich ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein es ist ein irrglaube
dass die jungen gar keine risiken haben
das steigt mehr oder weniger
proportional mit dem alter tatsächlich
an und jenseits der 14 sind das immer
noch überschaubare risiken aber keine 0
risiken auch da gibt es schon durchaus
schwere verläufe sehr wenig todesfälle
aber durchaus auch schwere verläufe auch
krankenhausaufenthalte das wünschen sich
viele auch nicht und vor allem muss man
sagen gerade leider bei den jungen
erwachsenen gibt es durchaus hohe raten
am so genannten long cupid syndrom alles
nicht dramatisch in der menge will ich
noch mal unterstreichen aber die
botschaft zu sagen dass sozusagen das
bei den jungen alles überhaupt kein
problem ist die sollte man so
tatsächlich nicht stehen lassen
also wir haben das gestern in den
nachrichten nur mal gab es dann mit den
nachrichten nach spanien geguckt in
katalonien mallorca gehen die inzidenz
in wieder hoch in katalonien barcelona
glaube ich 233 mallorca auch vor allen
dingen die jüngere sagt unsere
korrespondentin aber die intensivstation
füllen sich nicht also das spricht
ebenso ein bisschen dafür was sie sagten
verrückt dass das nun tatsächlich
auseinander geht aber das ist ja immer
der punkte die wissenschaftler sagen ja
eben okay wir brauchen langzeitstudien
und was longo witt angeht frage ich sie
jetzt das ist ja auch noch ein stochern
im nebel sozusagen das kann ja kein
mensch vorhersagen was vielleicht in
fünf sechs sieben jahren dann noch die
folgen sind oder das ist natürlich
richtig in die glaskugel können wir nur
bedingt schauen und vermutungen
anstellen
es ist noch offen ob sich das post
kowitz syndrom das lankowitz syndrom wie
sich das ganze auswirkt welche menschen
davon betroffen sind zum beispiel
menschen die nicht von ihrer infektion
wusste
das unbemerkt durch gemacht haben haben
die ein risiko für spätfolgen
auch dort das wird das sicher selten
seien aber ist das möglich wien trifft
es am ehesten wehrmacht überhaupt die
schwereren infektionen im verlauf durch
die müssen wir diese erkrankung
therapieren das sind denn das ist ein
voll ausgeprägten bild einer schweren
einer schweren longo wird syndrom eine
enorm gesundheitsbeeinträchtigende
situation
dafür müssen wir den ganzen mechanismus
besser verstehen dafür müssen wir
therapien entwickeln
wir müssen sehen ob menschen die bereits
vor erkrankt waren nach einer kurve
infektion
ihre organ schädigung beschleunigten
sozusagen im zeitraffer dass das sind
alles dinge wo wir ganz viel lernen
müssen und ich wollte noch mal auf die
auf die inzidenz und auch mit
zurückkommen und die maße ich denke wir
sind wir alle in der pandemie experten
geworden auch in der bevölkerung und die
inzidenz ist natürlich was was drin ist
und ich glaube auch dass viele menschen
verstehen dass jetzt zum einen die
inzidenz wieder hochgehen kann aber dann
die krankenhauseinweisung wurde
verstorbenen nicht aber im herbst kann
das möglicherweise auch wieder anders
werden und dann kann die inzidenz viel
schneller als gedacht wieder relevant
werden und dann kommt möglicherweise
wenn es wenn es schlecht läuft eine eine
variante die gefährliche ist dann ist
auch die inzidenz plötzlich vielleicht
wieder ein gutes maß also ich glaube wir
sollten auf mehrere faktoren gucken das
haben wir gelernt aber auf jeden fall
auch die inzidenz sozusagen nicht
vergessen also ich fasse zusammen was
sie beide so nett gesagt haben wir haben
keine glaskugel in die wir schauen
können
wir lassen aber sozusagen die regler
hoch was sie gesagt haben frau wuchs und
fahren weiterhin die antennen aus um ein
bisschen zu schauen wie man durch die
zukunft fährt die ergebnisse zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt die studie gibt es
unter www unimedizin mainz.de / pcs /
übersicht und insofern zum nachlesen und
reinschauen
ich glaube wir haben eine ganze menge
gelernt die fragen beantwortet und
insofern kann ich nur ein großes
dankeschön sagen an sie frau professor
büchs vielen vielen dank für die zeit
und die vielen vielen antworten auf die
fragen und vielen dank auch sie hier im
studio an sie herr professor wild vielen
vielen dank
ja ja und liebe userinnen und user wir
sagen dankeschön auch an sie dass sie
sich so rege beteiligt haben spannende
fragen gestellt haben und wir sagen
vielen vielen dank für ihr interesse und
ihnen einen schönen abend noch chips
oder wiedersehen